[Music]
if our world wasn't governed by laws
would you still know the difference
between right and wrong
if you desperately need food or shelter
what stops you from stealing it from
someone else well humans are one of the
only members of the animal kingdom to
have empathy and it's the main thing
keeping us from tearing each other apart
so how would we survive without it would
we be living in a world full of
Psychopaths this is what if and here's
what would happen if we were born
without empathy empathy is described as
the capacity to understand or feel what
another person is experiencing if you're
born without the ability to empathize
then you're most likely a psychopath
now not all psychopaths are dangerous
not like the ones in the movies still
you probably wouldn't want a world full
of them how would our society function
if everyone was just looking out for
themselves when you stand on a crowded
bus or subway train
what sort of connections do you feel
with your fellow passengers probably not
many you share the common activity of
taking public transit and that's about
it if we were all born without empathy
this is how a lot of our relationships
would feel our connections would be
emotionally shallow based around nothing
more than mutual interests shared
activities and personal desires if you
want to see what a world full of these
types of relationships would look like
just turn your attention to the animal
kingdom in 2017 researchers from Georgia
State University studied a group of
chimpanzees who demonstrated
psychopathic behavior their findings
provide an eerie window into how our
society would operate without empathy
first off there would be a lot of
deception and manipulation these chimps
were regularly observed faking emotions
to get attention and to influence those
around them every relationship they had
was just used as a means to an end based
on a continual exchange of favors
and they had no problem killing each
other to get what they want as long as
no one witnessed it
so how would these tendencies translate
to more complicated Minds like ours well
for one thing we'd have a very
competitive society but not necessarily
a very productive one no one would be
afraid to do whatever it takes to reach
their objectives so everyone would have
a lot of Drive but people would be
constantly undermining one another the
notion of society itself may quickly
begin to crumble with this lack of
collectivism if we're all walking around
just thinking about ourselves and why
would there be any reason for
technological advances you could spend
time developing advances to make more
money or you could just go steal
whatever you wanted with no remorse our
planet would also be pretty screwed why
would we put any effort into solving
problems that are only going to affect
future generations we'd be living in a
pretty dangerous world and would have to
highly structure itself to achieve any
level of success there would have to be
some sort of laws to avoid total chaos
but we probably wouldn't be able to
enforce them through punishment as we'd
all just focus on not getting caught
maybe a whole new legal system would
have to be set up that's a reward based
instead of punishment based but that's a
topic for another what if
[Music]
you